[Music]
hello and welcome back to the road to
2000 it's always I am your host Caleb
Denby today I wanted to continue the
kind of series I've been doing now on
the caro-kann of course in previous
weeks we take a look we took a look at
the advanced variation as well as the
exchange variation believe a long long
time ago I covered some classical lines
as well today I wanted to go over the
two nights variation in the caro-kann
and now this is kind of one that falls
by the wayside for a lot of carrot
cotton players they don't really analyze
the two nights because they think it's
just pretty similar to a lot of the
stuff they already know but you can't
run into some trouble if you don't know
what to what you're doing and there are
some really fun lines if you take the
time to study them so I wanted to
introduce you to some of those lines
here today with a few main games as well
as talking about a lot of different
variations within the lines that really
illustrate the character of the
positions so why don't we just get
started here the first game I'm going to
look at is between Pavel punker Tov
against Alexander Shimon ah've so of
course this game starts with the CARICOM
and now the main main caralyn variations
all start with the move d4 here but what
we're gonna look at today the two
Knights is aptly named because white
instead of playing d4 starts by
developing you guessed it the two
knights and we've arrived in the two
Knights variation here now there are a
lot of different moves that Carroll
players play here and the top two most
common moves I don't think are actually
Black's best lines and the reason
they're the most common moves is because
they're they're very carol like moves
and they get you into very Carol like
positions but white does sometimes gain
some things via this move order so the
most common move by far is Bishop g4
which is a very CARICOM style move you
just develop the bishop and now of
course white could transpose into some
other lines with d4 and it would be a
little bit weird but here I can actually
play mousse-like h3 and you have to give
up this bishop rather early and so I
don't really like the Bishop g4 lines
that much you can also take on e4 white
can take back and now unfortunately the
lines with Bishop f5 aren't quite as
good
for the reason that what weight has not
committed to d4 yet so these lines are
all coming a little bit quicker on the
Kings side so the line I'm actually
gonna recommend is pretty interesting
and I think it's the main reason why the
two Knights variation isn't the most
common especially at the top level the
line I'm gonna recommend actually starts
with Knight f6 and you might be thinking
well what's the big deal
well the big deal here is that you're
not allowing white to get into these
typical caro-kann positions where he
might have something to gain by delaying
the push of d4 instead you are forcing
the issue here with this pawn on e4 now
really the only line worth looking at
here is going to be what happens when
white pushes this pawn forward this is
really the only serious try for white
white can of course you know defend the
pawn with d3 at the very least here
black is going to be doing absolutely
fine after this Queen trade with perhaps
even a slightly better endgame white
could also try and move like Queen e2
but this moves just a little bit silly
and even the move d4 now for black kind
of illustrates that this is not really
what white wants to be doing pushing
this night all the way back to be - so
with that in mind we're gonna take a
look at the main stuff after e5 now of
course it would be silly for black to
bring the knight to f6 and then back to
g8 so the move is Knight e4 here now
I've drawn in very colorful arrows some
of the main options here for white of
course white can push d4 this is a
pretty common try let's see if I can get
my colors right here yeah d4 white can
also play the strange-looking move
Knight eetu and that's actually what
we're gonna analyze first then there are
some side moves like Queen e2 Bishop e2
h3 is playable even Knight takes e4
we're gonna take a look at eventually
but the main moves by far d4 and 92 so
in this line we're gonna take a look at
night e to first and this is a pretty
multi-purpose move here
the main reason white plays the move
Knight e2 is to of course prevent Knight
takes c3 white is looking to highlight
the fact that the black knight on e4 is
helps a little bit stuck on that central
square perhaps just a little bit stuck
now if you play a natural looking move
like e6000 defying in the center well
you're gonna run into d3 Knights e5
followed by d4 and if you bring this
knight back to d7 well what have you
done you've actually reached a French
down a tempo now I don't know if you're
familiar with the French but it's not
the kind of opening you really want to
play down a tempo of course you could
get similar positions by playing Knight
f6 to d7
but we've already committed this pawn to
c6 and this pawn is gonna have to move
to C c5 anyways in fact you might be
dumb like to Tempe but regardless it's
not worth playing so you can't just play
a simple move like II 6 you can but it's
it's quite bad so the line I'm
recommending is Queen b6 this is really
the the only main variation of course
Queen b6 makes a threat now the most
popular writer to respond with this is
really d4 kind of the only move again
just stopping the Queen from getting the
f2 well what has black gained by this
well you've gotten rid of this annoying
d3 line four four one here now I'm gonna
recommend you simply play e6 you could
theoretically try to develop this Bishop
but you're really going to run into some
problems after the move Knight F to G
one this is actually pretty awkward for
black it looks like a very very strange
move but the fact is your knight is
simply trapped after the move f3 and you
have a lot of problems to solve in the
mean time so instead of that movie 6
comes to mind now from here there are
two main branches in our main variation
here there's an H e3 which is what I'm
gonna look at in the main variation of
this game but I also wanted to take a
look at the move Knight FG one here and
this is in fact a playable move and in
fact this has been played in many many
games well over 100 players like MDL
have played it Alexander Grichuk and why
don't we see what happened in this MVL
game he was actually playing against
Vichy and not and this was actually from
the fourth field Cup in 2016 for curious
so st. Louis game right here the move
for black is going to be to play f6 this
is actually the only way to give your
knight a square now if white tries to be
persistent and
tonight on g5 well you simply have takes
on g5 takes on e5 rather you cannot
really recapture it due to this threat
and if f3 is still well your knight now
has some squares so h4 is ridiculous
can't play that f3 is the main move now
of course you gave you a knight the g5
square and E takes f6 is the natural
natural continuation G takes f6 now f4
hits this Knight again and you can bring
this Knight to either of these squares
I'm gonna recommend Knight e4 and now
Knight G 3 is the most common move for
weight just trying to harass this Knight
a little bit and after Bishop d7 this
Knight can capture takes c3 and snow in
this game between MVL and Vishy Anand
Anand actually played the move Knight a
6 and ended up winning the game quite
nicely but I prefer this line with c5 a
little bit and what happens here is
white usually pushes this pawn and you
end up with a little bit of craziness
where white ends up giving a check to
this king the King steps to d8 and you
have this really interesting position
where if you count the pawns are
actually even but the black King is a
little bit stuck in the center what does
black have in exchange for this well
pretty natural development with these
bishops and he's ahead a little bit in
development compared to all of White's
pieces on their starting squares yes so
has this nice central e4 pawn and I
quite like this for black actually the
main move is Bishop c4 and you can
respond to this with a really nice night
b4 idea here the point being if takes
Queen takes picks up this Bishop so I
went through that one rather fast here
oh and sorry Bensimon told me that there
was a question I had to answer because
there's a two dollar donation which
openings better Cara Condor French
defense I think you'll know my opinion
on that the French is for losers
the caro-kann is for winners do what you
will with that information so we went
through that pretty quickly here just to
back up the key point is Knight fg1
threatens to hit the threatens to trap
the knight f6 gives the native square
wipes now committed really to this f3
idea we go to g5 the only square
available takes takes
F for you can go to either square I
prefer the move 94 white challenges this
night and we developed with Bishop d7
now white can take we can take back c3
and I like the move
c5 rather than the knight a six that
fish sheet shows so you just develop a
little bit immediately challenge the
center and with your king you're
actually going to run to the c7 square
and just develop your pieces create a
nice little fortress around your king
and black is doing more than fine okay
so that is perhaps you know the most
forcing line from white here white plays
the move Knight fg1 threatening to trap
the knife that's when you go in for this
f6 idea the more common move perhaps the
better move is actually just to play
Knight g3 hitting this Knight directly
now there are a couple things you can do
you could take off this night
immediately opening the H file but the
better move is really just to play c5
here directly challenging the center
white doesn't really have time to take
because you can take back and d4 would
fall so instead the move Bishop d3 is
the most common hitting this Knight
again
now if you take on d4 well it's fine but
you're gonna get met with something like
this and d4 might be a little bit
difficult to a hold on to actually so
instead after Bishop d3 most common is
to take on g3 H takes g3 and take on d4
so what happens now
well white gets this active rook on the
H file and good coordination on the
Kings side in return black is crashing
through in the center and has already
won this pawn there are now a few
different moves we're gonna take a look
at from here but this is more or less
the the starting position of the main
main line in this caro-kann so what's
going on here well basically in all the
lines black is going to look to develop
in some manner usually these are the
squares the pieces come to this Bishop
also can come to e7 to take keep an eye
on the g5 square but generally ninety
six Bishop d7 and Bishop e7 or c5
depending on the line so it's kind of
what you want to be doing with the black
pieces
note that castling kingside sometimes it
comes on the board rarely it does
though this King site is really going to
come under fire and you have to be
really careful if you're committing your
King to this side of the board why don't
we just take a look at some lines though
so Knight takes d4 the most common move
in the database here is actually Knight
g5 just directly threatening this h7
pawn how should black respond while you
counter the attack on the side with
development and attacking in the center
so simply knight c6 white can take this
pawn if he likes but simply Bishop d7
and black is going to get develops and
this gets into some really really crazy
stuff in our main game here so I'm gonna
come back to this actually because this
is our main line and this is what was
played in the game between Poong panco
trove and Shimon off here so let's back
up a little bit Knight g5 looks the most
forcing looks the most testing but there
are some other moves here for white then
the a3 has actually seen some play just
keeping an eye on the B for a square and
really rather than preventing Bishop c4
the move is it's aimed at preventing is
really Bishop c5 and wants to reply to
Bishop c5 with the move b4 with tempo it
also is kind of acknowledging the fact
that the black King often ends up on the
Queen side it's kind of trying to get a
head start on this pawn rush on the
Queen side for that eventual future date
now the most common way to play here is
what I'm gonna recommend simply knight
c6 developing b4 for white is the
natural idea and continuation like I
said we simply develop our pieces now
the net Bishop comes to d7 the knight
comes to c6 Bishop f4 and now h6 is the
most common move for black here in fact
the only move in this game in the
database that I have here so h6 is a
nice idea to try and lock down some
squares on this King side g4 can come on
the board clean side castles as I said
black often puts the King over here now
the move g5 isn't really a threat here
you can simply take this and sacrifice
the exchange and this is going to be
actually really really good for black
because this exchange isn't even a
sacrifice excuse me because of these
threats
the kingside notes that this is a threat
and this is a threat and if Bishop g2
this is a threat so the tactics work out
here for black so queenside castles King
side castles is played in the game and
now simply g5 from black Bishop g3 and
Bishop e7 and in this game this is a
position from so lock against a leonov
and they actually ended up drawing but
black is pretty significantly better in
this position you're just gonna push
through with h5 and open things up on
this Kings side you have a nice central
pawn advantage and White has some work
to do before getting back into this game
so okay that's a little side note on a3
for you
a3 goes for b4 but in the end we're
still just going to develop our pieces
and play on the Kings side as such so
that's a three now perhaps the simplest
line for white you know there's this a
three line going for b4 there's Nike
five going for the Kings side what if
what of course if white simply
recaptures this pawn on d4 what happens
here
well of course Queen takes would be a
mistake the classic trap and the French
defense and the Cairo
Bishop e5 check picks up the Queen but
the line I'm gonna recommend is actually
Bishop c5 and this makes things rather
awkward for the white player now why is
that
well natural is to defend this night
with c3 we're simply gonna pile up the
pressure with knight c6 now we are
actually threatening to capture this
Knight the move Bishop e3 comes on the
board well you're gonna get met with
Bishop d7 and once again we're
threatening to capture this knight or
threatening to capture
e5 and things are gonna start falling
for white so instead why it most often
plays the move Knight takes c6 now of
course this allows Bishop takes f2
there's actually one game in this line
here that white ended up winning but I
think black had a very very nice
position and was in fact winning out of
the opening in this game that white
ended up winning and for those curious
this is Malta skaia against saw fur from
2017 there you go of course White has to
move out of the way with King f1 like
will recapture and in the game Queen G
was played Bishop e7 was blacks response
no taking this pawn is a little bit
suicidal black will actually simply
Castle queenside and these open files
around the king are going to be more or
less death for the white player in the
game King e2 was played and black missed
a very nice move here bishop g1 to
solidify the advantage Queen f3 might
have to be played to guard against Queen
f2 and now there are many moves but
perhaps Bishop a6 is the simplest just
removing the shelter around the White
King here okay yeah but in the game of
course that was missed and Bishop c5 was
played instead leading to an equal
position that white ended up winning
okay so that's a little side note on if
Knight takes d4 now fish of III Bishop
d7 and then Knight takes to c6
trying to avoid this well we simply take
on e3 and once again we are gonna have a
nice advantage this Knight really has
nowhere to go and we're taking on f2
next unless you play Knight d4 which of
course we can capture so once again the
three main moves here a3 Knight takes d4
and our main loot move in the game
Knight g5 and they all end up more or
less okay for black so let's go back to
the main line here with Knight g5 Knight
g5 yeah two knights against the Carroll
we'll get back to the the first few
moves momentarily but this is our main
variation here between panca Trev and
Shimon off so 95 hitting this pawn of
course we're gonna play knight c6 white
is going to capture this pawn that's
really the only sensible continuation
now Bishop d7 and wait to move and find
a tactic
see if you can find a tactic for the
white player here it's not a difficult
tactic but it is a rather complicated
one once you get into the variations so
white to move and win material for those
of you at home here
been playing the two nights for a while
and I've never seen this position before
as I said at the top of the show here
the two nights is kind of often
overlooked by caro-kann players and they
play it what I really think are slightly
inferior lines with Bishop g4 and with D
takes e4 rather than what I consider the
best move of three Knight f6 so it's not
as common to see from the white side
which should actually play in the black
the black players favor a little bit
okay
of course Knight f6 is the quote-unquote
tactic Knight f6 checks the king and
unveils this threat to the rook black of
course should take this tonight and now
rook takes h8 and what's going on here
well we're gonna castle making a threat
King f1 steps out of this threat and now
F takes e5 and we have a absolutely wild
position here where white is up in
exchange for a pawn technically I
believe that's the the pawn count it's a
little bit difficult to see but black
has achieved four central pawns that is
correct
count four central pawns four of them
four that's but I've never seen it
before
so okay four central pawns and there are
actually eight games in the database
here the one I'm gonna take a look at
was actually a game but played by ding
lurin with black in the Chinese league I
think his opponent a young thing that's
a terrifying name thing alright played
queen h5 hitting this pawn on f7 and
ding replied with E for and the game
between them actually continued for a
bit but with these central pawns black
is actually the one with an advantage
here for example simply Bishop e2 and in
the game ding played Bishop d6 which is
perfectly fine you can also play Bishop
e7 stockfish says the best move is f6
but I don't really understand it so I
like simply Bishop d6 Rick takes d8 was
not played in the game simply a3 was
played in the game and III for black led
to some interesting complications so
this is one that
I mean you can analyze it as deeply as
you like it's a really really complex
position just know that black should
actually have the edge with these
central pawns and there's gonna be a lot
of plans here for example you can go for
the super pawn square in the center
occupying every central square or this
move III that dangler end came up with
is actually quite nice
additionally there are some ideas of
playing moves like Bishop e8 and the
point here is that after some move like
Bishop g5 well you're you're gonna try
and advance a little bit with moves like
f6 and f5 in in the near future let's
say I'm more read more you know
laid-back move a little bit would be
like a four and okay I don't actually
like this move Bishop e8 I like the move
f5 immediately as as well the point
being blacks plan is eventually to
expand in the center here I threw in
this Bishop e8 move to try to do it with
tempo but you can simply just expand
right away it was like at five moves
like 'if I've moves like III this is how
blacks should play this position and if
you get this in a game I mean good luck
to you it's it's a wild one it's
happened like I said around eight times
before eight times this position has
been achieved by strong level players so
okay in the game though in our main game
this of course was not ad Engler endgame
the game we're looking at was a queen a
dr was actually played and this is much
less common than king f18 games king f1
this is the only game where queen h5 was
played and black simply takes back on e5
no need to do anything while and crazy
you don't really need to memorize this
line just play natural moves you take
and take and try to expand in the center
let's see the natural conclusion this
game though Bishop g5 is played hitting
this rook and now is the time to play
with some activity Queen takes b2 for
black hitting the rook rook d1 saving
the rook now Bishop b4 is a Czech king
f1 black takes off this rook on h8 as it
was attacked here Queen takes h8 and
simply king c7 the game continued now
with c3 and D takes c3 and black is
simply winning here c3 is a losing move
although like I said black does have
some advantage perhaps queen g7 is a
better try when like I said black is
gonna start expanding with moves like f5
and this little pawn blob is gonna run
up the board and try and kill try and
kill white black is also more or less
just winning on the Queen side as well
and moves like a5 a5 a4 a3 a2 a1 and are
also going to become threats if this a
pawn ends up falling okay in the game
though c3 and now after D takes c3 this
past pawn is simply too much and Shimin
off won this game pretty easily here
Bishop b2 and now Queen a1 check now
Queen d1 is a fork rook takes b2 pawn
takes b2 Queen h7 and E 4 interferes
with this connection Bishop f4 check u 5
now note back up Center pawns are always
good too and here white actually
resigned so very nice game from black
and this is why I really like this
variation for black all of the lines
look really fun to play and pretty
complex as well but the difference is
for most black openings that look really
fun to play and really complex black
usually ends up worse you know
maybe you can play like the knight or if
it's really complex and fun and you're
like equal but in these lines white is
the one who ends up on the backfoot
because the two knights really I don't
think is the best line for for white so
with these main lines for black I really
like his chances here and white can very
very easily end up on the back foot
so just to recap here and the main line
I just showed he for c6 Knight c3 d5
Knight f3 the two Knights variation of
the caro-kann the main two moves here
are Bishop g4 and D takes e4 but I'm
recommending the third most popular move
Knight f6 I think this is the best line
for black e 5 is the only line worth
considering Knight e4 now and these are
the main moves for white in this game we
were looking at all the lines after 92
when Queen b6 is the move to hit f2
force this pawn to d4 and now e 6 and
you end up with some really interesting
stuff
where black is attacking in the center
of the board just to quickly play
through the main line once again Knight
g3 c5 attacking the center Bishop d3 we
trade nights and take in the center and
then we looked at these three main
options for white and the plans for
black were similar in each you develop
your pieces out Castle queenside or in
the main line you know go wild and
tactically get this this massive pawn
center so that is the main variation of
the two knights that I'm going to go
over now backing up to this starting
position here we're gonna look next at
the line with d4 but first this was a
lot to cover
I'm gonna open it up to any questions to
the YouTube chat before I move on this
92 line is honestly the most critical
and might not be the most common move
that you actually face in the database
that's the most common in practice I've
actually run into d4 a lot more than 92
but open it up to questions because this
line is really really critical and
really complex as well
why Castle queenside that's a perfectly
good question
let's so in the 95 line it's pretty
obvious why you Castle queenside your
center your King side kind of falls
apart but looking at another line like a
three here well why are you gonna Castle
queenside and the fact is g5 if you end
up let's say black plays a little bit
more naively simply there should be
seven that's not a bad move at all and
white plays move like king f1 now if we
Castle kingside the move like G I move
like g5 is simply winning Bishop takes
h6 is probably winning Queen d2
preparing Bishop takes h6 is probably
winning
let me flip on the engine here it looks
like it's plus six and a half
so don't Castle kingside in this line
you're just gonna get destroyed by this
open H file that's that's why you'll
want to go Queen side the open H file is
way too dangerous
any other questions what about Knight
takes Knight Knight takes Knight is not
at all the most popular move here we're
gonna take a look at it once we get to
the sidelines here we'll look at d4 next
though look at d4 next any other
questions any other questions okay so
more questions about this sideline well
look at this sideline last it's really
not the most popular move so let's move
on to four d4 to do so we're gonna take
a look at our main game here between
play by the name of nosh I hope I'm
pronouncing correctly and Peter Prohaska
Peter actually recently I believe moved
to st. Louis he's going to one of the
st. Louis schools I think it's Webster
once again we have the two Knights
Knight f6 v5 really the only move 94 now
in last variation in the last game we
took a look at 92 now we're gonna look
at the d4 lines and those are really by
far the two most popular responses to
this line with white just to give you
some numbers in the database I have here
there are three hundred and ten games
with 92 there's 108 games with d4 and
there's less than 40 games in every
other variation so d4 a really mainline
now there are two moves that you can
really play here
the most common move is actually Knight
takes c3 but I'm gonna recommend the
second most common move Queen a5 and now
there are only 12 games in this Queen a5
line but I think it's simply an
improvement on
takes c3 the reason for that being you
quite often get similar positions too if
you take on c3 immediately but your
queen is a little bit improved on the AF
v squared that's that's my claim at
least so queen a5 and now the most
common response to this is actually
Bishop d2 trying to highlight that this
queen can't stay on a5
however with Bishop d2 the move Knight
takes D to is what I'm gonna recommend
and that's what was played in this game
as well and by taking off this dark
square Bishop the black King starts to
feel a little bit safer by removing this
piece you can much more comfortably play
moves like h6 whenever you need to and
you have to worry less about these
Bishop takes h6 sacrifices it's it's a
really nice thing to kind of have off
your mind
no Bishop takes h6 never gonna be legal
in this game so Knight takes d2 in the
main variation I do wanna mention the
move Bishop d3 is also actually playable
and it has been played a few times
against this I'm gonna simply recommend
you know normal development here Bishop
g4 threatening this knight on f3 now of
course if takes will take back and we're
on this night so white most often
castles and now Knight takes c3 is the
move of course White has unpinned with
this previous with his previous move so
tonight takes c3 B takes e3 e6 Bishop d2
now is the most common move for white
making some threats like this but simply
Bishop e7 for black c4 can come on the
board for white we're gonna drop this
Queen back to c7 and now after C takes
d5 C takes d5 it's just simply a game
here this is more or less equal from
what I can tell it's kind of an improved
French we've got our Bishop out out of
the pawn chain and we do have some nice
pressure on the Queen side here but of
course why it's gonna have some
compensation for this with some play on
the Kings side as well white also has
some ideas of playing this move c4 and
in fact in the only game I found in the
database here rook c1 was played and
Bishop a3 rook be one was black's choice
black then repeated with Bishop e7 and
players agreed to a draw after Bishop e7
or c1 there are other moves you can play
though for example simply knight c6 is
totally playable and after c4 you can
reply with Queen d7 and you might end up
in some position looking like this where
you have some pressure on the d4 pawn
but White has a little bit more space
it's just kind of a balanced position ok
enough on Bishop d3 though I was just
highlighting that you just end up taking
on c3 eventually playing east six and
you get your Bishop out of the pawn
chain first with a slightly improved
French okay though Bishop d2 is our main
move it's the most common move from
white so it's what we're gonna focus on
in the game Peter per Houska takes this
Bishop off the board as I'm recommending
Queen takes d2 was White's reply and now
simply Bishop f5 and once again we're
simply aiming for an improved French
here with Bishop f5 however the
difference is this time wait can kind of
prevent it White has this nice move
tonight
h4 hitting this Bishop and so the bishop
has to drop back you can kind of come
out to g4 but really you're only helping
white here moves like Queen afore are
actually something white wants to do
anyways it was like h3 are also on
White's mind so don't come to g4 simply
drop back to d7 it's totally fine now in
the game white played at Bishop d3 black
played e6 and white actually found
nothing better than to drop this Knight
back to f3 so what have we achieved by
this maneuver well I think we actually
gained a tempo by forcing way to move
this night a couple of times back and
forth
okay now c5 comes on the board for black
and we just challenged the center very
natural play the classic kind of French
plans here so c5 challenging the center
white in the game actually kind of
budged and took on deep took on c5 black
played Knight a6 trying to recapture
with the knight simply queen f4 from
White Queen b4 was black's choice trying
to get these Queens off the board of
course most of White's play is coming on
the King side in the form of a mating
attack so trading Queens is always gonna
be a good idea here for black queen c1
was played in the game guarding this
pawn now Knight takes e5 and things have
really gone
for black in this game and it takes D
three takes D three rook c8 white now
has two bishops pressure on the C file
and a very nice game a very very nice
game ahead I'm gonna call this kind of
the end of opening but we'll take a look
at the rest of this game as well Peter
played a very nice game here a three was
played Queen b6 Queen a for back now
Bishop e7 just getting developed queen
g4 once again it would be a mistake to
Castle kingside here you're already
actually hanging tactics like Knight
takes d5 so just leave your king in the
middle it's fine and in fact Peter could
take on b2 here white kind of went for
broke with Queen takes g7 simply rook f8
is defending now Knight takes d5 was
played but peter simply goes up a piece
now rook b1 Queen takes a three rook
takes b7 between a six and this game
quickly ended in Peters favor
queens were traded and here black is
simply up a rook and winning the game
king b6 h v a5 was the last move of the
game and Peter walks away with a win
okay so I went through these lines a lot
faster they're a little bit simpler with
d4 I see a little question where was
this played I think this was a World
Team Championship I think I think it was
a team championship tough to tell it was
played somewhere in the realm of 2013 to
2014 perhaps nobody does know where this
game came from I just found it in the
database so any questions on d4 what's
the bishop doing on d7 okay so the sent
upon loss from white a hundred plus I'm
not super worried about the sent upon
loss I'm worried more about the plans
for each side and how each side should
be playing white actually played pretty
naturally here going for an attack on
the Kings side but blacks play in the
center and on the Queen side is always
going to be enough if played well why
didn't Queen takes c3 after Knight takes
c6 c5 losing a tempo is not bad maybe
well in this case we actually gain at
go back by playing Bishop f5 in Bishop
back to d7 and a little note on why it
looks like we're playing the French down
a tempo well in this case even if we
work directly down a tempo we would have
gotten this very very favorable exchange
where we trade off our g8 Knight or f6
Knight depending on how you want to
phrase it for the dark squared Bishop
this is a really favorable exchange for
black and so that's what black is
getting by moving this Knight out to f4
so early on and playing c6 followed by a
c5 rather than c5 and one tempo note
that also in this other line with Bishop
d3 where we end up taking on c3 we also
have a slightly more favorable exchange
now some of you might be familiar with
this pawn structure in frenches of
course this punch Heckscher is normally
achieved by Bishop b4 followed by Bishop
takes c3 and we would much prefer to
trade off our g8 night for this knight
on c3 rather than our dark squared
Bishop so it's a more favorable exchange
and we also get this Bishop outside the
pawn chain so that's why it's worth it
here for black to waste a little bit of
time with c6 and c5 good question though
ok why doesn't Queen takes c3 after
Knight takes I'm a little bit ok here I
see so Bishop d2 well I don't think we
ever took on c3 I'm a little confused
yeah I'm a little confused by it by your
statement in the line with Bishop d3 of
course Queen takes c3 actually wasn't
legal we we took the piece here so
points don't move what Knights butts
okay oh I see what you're saying why not
Queen takes c3 here or perhaps you're
saying yeah I guess you're staying here
well the answer is it's simply not worth
the time to take here rook b1 is gonna
be a really strong move if you're not
careful and if you play with like b5 to
defend it simply e6 now and you're kind
of getting destroyed you got to be a
little bit careful like Bishop takes e6
it's gonna be met with Knight g5 and
this guy's attacked Knight back to d7
Queen f3 and all of a sudden pressure is
kind of mounting there's discovered
threats there's threats on f6 if you
play move like I have six well then
Bishop takes or Bishop g6 is picking up
the Queen so things can get a little
hairy pretty fast so don't waste your
time picking up this double pawn you
need to develop instead note that if a
move like rook b1 is played now it's
perfectly fine we drop the Queen back to
c7 and we stay a little bit more solid
here just a little bit more solid okay
any other questions
mm okay well in that case I am going to
move on once again first of all actually
let me do a quick little review so in
the first variation we took a look at 92
now we're looking at d4 when I'm
recommending Queen i5 hitting this
Knight most common move for white is
Bishop d2 where we take this bishop and
then kind of develop into a normal
French where we have this favorable
exchange Bishop d3 is also playable
where we get this bishop outside the
pawn chain once again and end up taking
this knight on c3 so just play through
it Bishop d2 we take the bishop develop
our Bishop Place c5 and go for this
attack in the center D takes c5 was
played in the game night a6
to recapture favorably white goes for
attacks on the Kings side we go for
pressure on the Queen side and due to
the opening play blacks pressure on the
Queen side is really more than enough
here we can see one and I take c5 and
black is already better white could of
course play other moves here like even
King side castles is playable maybe a
move like a three but simply Knight
takes e5 and once again blacks pressure
in the center and on the Queen side is
gonna be enough for for him here okay
let's move on to some sidelines so let's
see Knight f6 v five Knight takes e4 now
there are a wide variety of sidelines
here I'm actually gonna go over five
different lines for white kind of
briefly here I don't want to spend too
much time on each of these because these
are really not the most common moves why
don't we start with what some of you
probably think is the most natural move
taking this knight on e4 that's probably
what you're worried about
with this variation when you first see
it so Knight takes e4 okay Knight takes
e4 D takes e4 of course our opponent
took her Knight we're going to take it
back
Knight g5 now is trying to pick up this
pawn but play from here for black is
actually pretty natural you simply play
the move Queen d5 and try to pick up
this pawn note that d4 is a move for
white you simply take on
sont bishop takes and take this pawn for
free Mike it's a little bit of
development but up upon up a center pawn
nonetheless this should be totally
totally fine for black and you can just
kind of develop naturally with this
Knight play move like e6 and get this
Bishop out and life is totally totally
fine for black the most common move
though is Queen e2 Queen takes d5 is
playable here I'm actually gonna
recommend the move Bishop f5 being a
little bit more annoying to the opponent
really holding on to this EEP on for
dear life
now if white ends up really really
knowing what they're doing they might
play like a Chinese player by the name
of shang lei Lu with the move g4 hitting
this Bishop and the point is after
Bishop to g6 Bishop tg2 is the point to
pick up this pawn fear not though now
we're ready to capture on e5 Knight
takes e4 but now the move h5 is quite
nice for black and g5 by White is
already giving up a lot of dark a lot of
light squares excuse me
such as f5 Bishop takes e4 is the most
common move now in the game between
Shing lei Lu and away.you
Shang Leia actually played the move g6
here which is a pretty interesting try
to get at the black King you can't
really save this Bishop anyway in the
game way you tried f5 and the move f3
was played to take advantage of this pin
97 takes on e4 and here away you simply
plays a 6 takes on f5 Queen takes f5 and
this pawns a little bit weak the game
continued with Queen e4 and way you
simply plays Bishop c5 and the game
continued from here and that one
actually ended in a draw so this is
perfectly fine for black blacks of
course going to end up castling
queenside once again and this pawn might
just be a little bit overextended as
compensation though White has two
bishops in this e six pawn isn't ideal
either should be totally fine here
if you're curious the game did continue
with the move c3 Queen takes e4 Czech
Bishop takes e4 Knight over to f6
Bishop c2 in E five so black gets a
little bit of an edge in the center as
well okay so that's what happens on
Knight takes e4 any questions there so
96 before we take back and play Queen d5
now there's really no way for white to
hold on to this pawn we looked at d4
when we simply take it off the board and
take Eve five we also looked at Queen e2
when I'm recommending Bishop f5 where
are you going for a slightly weird
looking line but you eventually just
take this anyways perfectly fine stuff
perfectly fine stuff please get a new
haircut I want to but the world's ending
and all the haircut places are closed
trust me dude
I want a haircut is not happening okay
that's enough on Knight takes e4 then
and to be totally honest with you I very
very rarely have faced Knight takes e4
in my own games here at most white
players kind of understand that Knight
takes e4 is not the way to go against
this line now let's look at what I'm
gonna call the most relevant side line
which is well actually let's look at
that later
we'll look at our main variation last
let's start with Queen e2 here Queen e2
is a move that has been played 30 times
is like the fourth or fifth most common
reply for white and to show you how to
play this way I'm going to actually go
over a game here between Yong Nepal
mushy and legendary player Anatoly
Karpov with the black pieces now in this
game Anatoly actually ended up losing to
yan with the white pieces but he had a
very nice position out of the opening so
that's what we really care about don't
be deceived by the results of the games
all the time
Knight takes c3 is black strip light D
takes c3 now Karpov caro-kann legend
plays Bishop g4 of course develop the
bishop outside the pawn chain you're
playing the caro-kann okay
h3 from white forces black's hand here
but should takes f3 is played Queen
takes f3 and now simply e6
and we get this interesting position
White has the two bishops more space in
the center and as always he's going for
an attack on this King side meanwhile
Black has a slightly better pawn
structure more control over the d4
square and pretty natural development so
let's see how the game continued pretty
much exactly as you might expect Bishop
f4 97 challenges the center supports c5
Queen side castles and then Anatoly came
up with this nice move b5 just
immediately going after white on the
Queen side h4 was played and now a very
common response to age 4 in the
caro-kann is actually this move h5 just
to lock things down a little bit on the
Kings side however of course black or
white can break through any ways to move
g4 which is what Yan did in the game it
shakes g4 Queen takes g4 Queen c7 it's
perfectly fine move challenging this
pawn rook e1 from white defense and this
is where Anatoly started going a bit
wrong he has a perfectly fine position
here in fact I think black is actually a
little bit better in the game Anatoli
Castle queenside which is not an awful
move but it's a little bit better
actually to just keep this King in the
center and just launched these pawns up
the board and go after white on the
Queen side and it's gonna be a really
really fun game opposite sides castling
you know somebody's getting checkmated
here it's it's gonna be a good time so
that's what I'm recommending against
Queen e2 basically your fallback against
most of these lines is you take on c3
develop this Bishop and then play a
caracal type position where white often
cast its Queen side and you can go after
him with an attack this is kind of the
fallback for this line so that's Queen
e2 why don't we take a look now at the
move Age 3 and you might think this move
is stupid and why would white play this
move well if you've been paying
attention and all the lines we just
looked at like Queen e2 what is black do
here
well they move the bishop out to g4 so
the idea of h3 is to kind of stay a
little bit cagey and simply prevent
Bishop g4 before black ever has the
chance
now there are a couple things you can do
here I'm just gonna recommend East six
you know give up on Bishop g4 give up on
developing this Bishop because
thankfully we've forced White's hand
into kind of wasting a tempo with this
move h3 so that's what we get in
exchange for keeping our Bishop behind
the pawns here so Queen e2 could be
played and now Knight takes c3 do you
take c3 sorry do you take c3 not Queen
d3 and the move c5 is going to come fur
black and once again it's going to be a
very very similar position to what I
just looked at the difference here being
these Knights are still on the board
it's a slight difference but it
shouldn't make too much of a difference
in the game Queen c7 for example g4
knight c6 even and in this game white
actually tried c4 and D takes c4 and
black is actually significantly better
already
ie five is coming under some fire and
moves like b5 are are on on the cards
for black if white doesn't recapture
here so this was actually another game
between shang lei Lu and ding Lauren
that they played I guess they played the
caret Khan a couple times and went for a
couple interesting different lines
so that's h3 once again you just take on
c3 but the difference with h3 is that it
doesn't let black develop this Bishop
not too different okay let's look at
another line here what if d3 challenging
the night I'm gonna let you viewers at
home guess the next move for black here
you should have some idea of what blacks
fallback is against all these
weird-looking lines so d3 what do you
want to play
what do you want to play here okay
there's a bit of a delight I'm gonna
assume the chat all said Knight takes c3
cuz they've been paying very good
attention of course this is our fallback
and then we developed this Bishop and
play a French style of position so I
think you can kind of guess blacks next
five moves white takes here black
develops this Bishop white challenges
the bishop we trade on f3 play e6 and
then in this game black chose Queen c7
before playing a move like c5 it's
perfectly fine though Bishop d3 see five
castles knight c6 Bishop e3 that should
be seven Queen g3 and in this game black
went for g6 and black is perfectly fine
here the game continued with rook a to
be 1 and here black made a little bit of
a misstep by planning to move a 6 Mike
did go on to win this game though this
is a game between a Paulette and Berg
and 2014 yeah there you know some
mid-level strong players c4 would
actually be a better move for black here
forcing this bishop back and then a move
like h5 kind of locks things down on the
kingside know once again
Black is not committing the King to
castling kingside in any of these lines
don't do it you'll get checkmated it
hurts really bad it's happened to me
learn from my mistakes okay so yeah d3
is okay for white but we just go back to
this fallback plan
lastly now I want to take a look at the
main variation and that involves the
players you see on your screen here
Levon Aronian and England Bishop e2 is
actually the most common of these
quote-unquote sidelines that I've
decided to analyze here today once again
you can probably guess our next move
that's right we're falling back to
Knight takes c3 Knight takes c3 D takes
c3 and now Bishop g4 the same moves
we've been looking at now why is Bishop
e2 the most common of these sidelines
well the reason for that is that now
after Bishop e2 the knight is not
actually pins and
white can force perhaps a slightly more
favorable trade of the two LightSquared
bishop s-- rather than the LightSquared
bishop for this night this night is
actually a really good piece and can
often be involved in sacrifices to get
at the king to open things up so white
keeps the night in favor of trading off
these bishops as did Levon Aronian in
this game against jingler end game can
the game continued with a six you have
to kind of stop a six for white and just
the natural moves that we've been
looking at all day long here in these
sidelines now queen g4 for white is
putting some pressure on the Jeep on
simply ninety seven is played
challenging a five-night back to f3
defense and then Dingle Arendt came up
with a really nice move here to this
place the king the queen rather that
move of course I'm talking about is
simply age five now in this game white
chose to bring the Queen to f4 and black
perhaps missed a little bit of an
opportunity here to take the initiative
so let's see if you all at home can find
an interesting way to take the
initiative with black to try and create
some immediate problems for white see if
you can find it see if you can find it
I'm talking to you at home
if I ever beaten an iamb or GM yes
why does white play why does white not
play B takes c3 like taking towards the
center B takes c3 is actually a playable
move but it really just transposes to
those d4 lines where you're talking
about
so I'll review that briefly though but
for now interesting way for black to
take the initiative does anybody see it
nobody seems to see it okay well here's
the answer for those of you at home I'm
of course talking about this
weird-looking move Queen c7 now what is
it attained by this well why it's gonna
probably play a natural move like
castles or a 4 it doesn't really matter
set castles and now black can reply it
with f6 and you're really solving these
problems in the center immediately f6
interesting move II take SEP 6 black can
go for a queen trade take back on f6 and
after and move like g3 simply king f7
and black has a nice advantage in the
center of the board here and really no
problems with this King now that the
trade has been forced so that would have
been a nice line for black instead ding
Lauren kind of did the classical Carroll
convoy of playing now for those of you
unfamiliar a huge advantage to the
caro-kann is that black doesn't really
create many weaknesses if any at all and
ding Lauren chose to take that to heart
in this game and really played the rest
of the game was simple peace maneuvering
not really committing to any pawn pushes
any pawn thrusts and it worked to his
benefit here because white could not
find a way to break through h4 was
played in the game now Knight f8 is
black's
new vert queen g3 Knight g6 all of a
sudden pressure on this pawn Bishop to
g5 is played now Queen c7 is putting
some pressure here once again moves like
f6 are kind of being threatened so
Bishop takes c7 now Queen takes e7 Queen
side castles Queen side castles once
again not going king side not going
Kings side rook H e1 and then ding
Lauren came up with a really nice
maneuver actually Queen f8 was his
choice and the point of this move is it
simply defends g7 white played rook d3
but now a g7 defended a black improves
as knight to this nice f5 square quite
simply really natural play from ding 94
is played
and now g6 solidifies this night over
here on f5 when g5 was played in the
game
Queen h6 trades the Queen's and now
after g3 rook h8 Knight f3 King d 7c for
King g7 black gets the King to the
center for the endgame k3 rook e8 ding
Lauren even refuses to give his opponent
that move a 6 refuses any weaknesses at
all c5 now b6 Brooks III and d4 was
finally played ding finally pushes the
pawn here Brooke a 3 now rook HB 8 wreck
a for ending takes off this pawn on c5
plays Rick b5 and at the end of the day
this ended up being agreed to a draw
here with ding upon and this is a game
from actually the st. Louis Rapide
Rapide and blitz I think this was a
rapid game though in 2019 just last year
I think those dings first appearance in
that tournament actually so ding uses
the caro-kann achieves a draw now there
was a question I promised I would go
over 94 Bishop e2 why it doesn't white
recapture with the b-pawn taking towards
the center and of course this is
actually an OK way an OK way of playing
excuse me but we're simply gonna
transpose to a lot of the lines with d4
so let's go back to this line for
example if white plays d4 here we take
on c3 in this line with Bishop d3 Knight
takes c3 is eventually played first
Bishop g4 castles no knight takes c3 and
you get this kind of structure that we
looked at before
once again black gets kind of an
improved flinch with this Bishop outside
the pawn chain and these Knights
exchanged with the dark squared Bishop
still on the board and the plans are
still black plays on the Queen side
natural stuff any other questions on the
two knights variation of the caro-kann I
think this I hope this was mostly
comprehensive this should be most of the
stuff you guys face if you decided to
employ this variation with black over
the board or even an online chess once
again the main ideas for black really
you just try to get an improved type of
French position
you bring this Knight to e4 trade it off
for this knight on c3 and just play
chess from there it's just a chess game
okay I'm not seeing any other ideas any
other questions really pawn hanging on
c3 well yeah once again you you don't
you don't really want to take this pawn
yes it's a little little bit dangerous
to go pawn hunting here a little bit
dangerous
in fact Bishop d2 is the main move but
for example Rick b1 you just drop back
to c7 it's fine it's fine
okay well then that's gonna be it for me
tonight on chess openings explained if
you're watching live and be sure to head
over to our twitch channel where the
action will still continue with a fun
little tactics time class that I have
for you guys if you're watching the
YouTube replay well thank you very much
for watching either way no matter how
you're watching be sure to tune in next
week for another chess openings
explained with yours truly
Caleb Dunphy I will see you then good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you